[Music]
kalpen farmer Armen couple has never
followed the crowd he's a free spirit
who's always done his own thing
and he's someone who usually gets what
he wants
sooner or later and what he wants now is
that cows get to keep their horns
although they are all born with horn
nubs in Switzerland eight out of ten
calves are dehorned this is often
painful for the cattle for couple it's
clearly Cruelty to Animals the Creator
equipped cows with horns so for me it's
only natural that they belong to the
animal system you know I'm eating this
so he started campaigning to let swiss
cows hold on to their horns for years he
tried to do this through petitions but
the authorities and the politicians
wouldn't listen so he launched his horn
cool or horned cow initiative and
against all odds collected more than 150
thousand signatures enough for a
referendum on the matter in a few months
Switzerland's more than five million
voters will decide and arming kapow
stands a good chance of winning despite
opposition from the government the
Parliament and the Association of Swiss
cattle breeders company scientists so us
can't be that something like whether
cows have horns or not becomes part of
the Constitution look at these cows here
how they're all standing around us so
calm and peaceful I don't think these
animals are lacking for anything and
cows with horns significantly raise the
risk of accidents hmm Armand Capello
says the notion that cow horns increased
the risk of injury is nonsense he says
that in his stall the cows used their
horns to communicate
she offered the tip of her horn to
another cow so it could clean dirt out
of its I developer that who's a
Cleveland she stuck out her horn and the
other one went like this Capello knows
he can't ban dehorning entirely he jokes
that if he tried to do that someone
might set fire to his cow stall instead
he's seeking financial assistance for
farmers who let their cattle keep their
horns that's because these cows need
more space in the stall and dehorned
ones his opponents say couples
initiative would cost 30 million Swiss
francs where would the money come from
it'd have to be taken out of domestic
agriculture there certainly wouldn't be
any more direct payments or subsidies
and that would mean more discontent
amongst farmers but the battle against
dehorning is really about creating more
nature-oriented agricultural policies
something Armen capão plans to keep
fighting for now he must find funding
for his referendum campaign he paid for
everything himself so far but now his
wife has taken the bull by the horns and
forbidden him from doing it again